PROFESSOR: Continue today.
We're still in the
spirit of origami.
And we're going to do some
origami design and foldability
again.
There are two main topics
here on the design side
we're going to talk about--
universal hinge patterns, which
are the things that make
underlying this robot, which
I showed in lecture one.
You may recall.
So it's called a
box pleat pattern.
It's a square grid with
alternating diagonal creases.
And the idea with
the robot is you're
constrained to only-- you have
to build the creases ahead
of time.
You can't say, you
can't build one sheet
that can fold
anywhere at anytime.
You want to build
a sheet that can
fold at any of the crease
lines, at the built
crease lines whenever you want.
And so whereas with
something like Origamizer,
every design has a completely
different crease pattern
and it's difficult to
control that, here we
wanted to make one.
It's not exactly
a crease pattern,
because you're not
using all the creases.
It's what we call
a hinge pattern,
all the possible places
you could fold that thing
and make lots of
different shapes
from that one hinge pattern.
So that's the first
part of the lecture.
And the second part of the
lecture will be about hardness.
And we'll see, I think,
four different kinds
of origami problems
which are all NP-hard.
And I'll tell you
what NP-hard means.
And we'll prove all that.
So there are lots
of problems that
are computationally intractable.
And we're going to cluster them
all together into one lecture.
Because it's kind of fun
to see them together.
Mostly we've been talking
about positive results so far.
All right, so let's do
universal hinge patterns.
This is pretty recent work.
It just appeared at the
big origami math conference
this summer.
And its work by Nadia, and me,
and Marty, and Aviv Ovadya,
who I think actually came out
of this class three years ago,
if I recall.
It just took us awhile
to write it all up.
And it's why the robot
has a box pleat pattern.
So the idea is to require that
the crease pattern of whatever
you want to fold must be a
subset of some fixed hinge
pattern.
And the goal is to make one
hinge pattern to rule them
all, one hinge pattern
that you can make anything.
I mean you can't make literally
anything, I don't think.
I was wondering
about this yesterday.
But we're not going to
try to make everything out
of one hinge pattern.
But we want to make
lots of different things
somehow from one hinge pattern.
And here's the theorem
that formalizes
this idea of lots of things.
We're going to take the box
pleat pattern from an n by n.
Grid so that's you take
a square grid, n by n.
And then you fill in
alternating diagonals.
Then that thing
that hinge pattern
can make by using a
subset of those creases,
you can make any
polycube of n cubes.
I'm sorry, order n cubes.
And what else?
You can even do it seamless.
So a polycube made of n cubes
is just you take n cubes.
And you start
gluing them together
face to face until you
have one connected monster.
And that's a polycube.
So you can make, for
example, I don't know,
all the Tetris pieces.
Tetris pieces would
be four cubes.
Normally they're squares, but
you can 3-dimensionalize them.
That's a four cube polycube.
And you get the general idea.
So this is cool because
there are exponentially
many polycubes with n cubes.
And here is one pattern
that can make all of them.
And if you imagine
some crazy 3D shape,
you can, of course,
approximate it by cubes,
sort of voxelization
is the usual term,
the same way that
we pixelize images.
And then you can make
basically anything
you want up to the resolution
provided by your sheet.
So that's the sense in
which this is universal.
So let's prove that.
It's actually not too hard
to do in at least one way.
The first idea is to build
something called a cube gadget.
We're going to use the idea
of a gadget a lot, especially
in this lecture.
But in general, it's a
useful algorithmic tool.
A gadget is just something
that you reuse many times.
It's like a tool.
And in this case, we're going
to use this folding many times.
At a high level, it's just
a way to fold a single cube.
But it has lots of
nice properties.
So this is a crease pattern.
Red lines are mountains.
Blue dashed lines are valleys.
It folds into this thing,
which you can see is a cube.
Here it's some
semi-transparent material.
And there's some pleats coming
out in the four directions.
But it's basically
a cube on a plane.
So we started with a
plane, a rectangle.
We fold that pattern.
And you get a rectangle
plus a cube sticking out.
OK, so in particular, I can make
a one cube polycube out of this
if I just made this, got
rid of the rectangular part.
But by using this
gadget n times,
I claim I can make
an n cube polycube.
And this kind of a crazy
idea that, so for example,
suppose the starting sheet
was not just a rectangle.
But suppose it was a rectangle
with a cube sticking out
right here.
I could still do this folding.
Because this folding
didn't touch The gray lines
are not creases.
They're just hinges.
If I had a cube sticking out
here. and I folded this thing,
it would now be a rectangle
with a cube in the center
and a cube sticking
out of this corner.
Because that corner just
folds to right there.
In fact, I could have a cube
sticking out right here also.
And then there'd be a
cube sticking out here
in the finished product.
And the idea is to just
keep using this gadget.
And make your sheet
bumpier and bumpier
with more and more
cubes sticking out.
And this is the
sort of thing if you
wanted to make-- so
there I had cubes
that were separated
from each other.
If you want to have cubes that
are attached to each other,
you can do that too.
Because all right, say here,
if you apply the cube gadget
at this center
square, so you want
to pull a cube out from there.
Maybe I should show you
in the previous diagram.
So you have these four squares
around the center square
make up the four sides of the
cube, other than the top side.
And so if you already had
a cube on that side face,
when you fold this
thing, you end up
with a cube that has a
cube attached on its right.
So if I wave my hands
enough, I believe
that it's possible to
make anything in this way.
Let me convince you a
little more formally.
Let's see.
Here's a real example.
It gives you an idea of
how you can make even
overhanging cubes.
All I did was initially
I made this first cube.
Then I made this cube with
this one attached to the side,
just like the previous picture.
And then I just made another
cube right underneath that one,
so this cube was already
attached to the center square.
And it just got raised
up by another cube.
So now you've got
this L overhang.
And this is not quite
the crease pattern.
This is there's some lines
that are not drawn here.
But it's a rough sketch
of the crease pattern.
Let's see.
I'll worry about the rest next.
Let me give you a little bit
of an argument why this works.
So a cube gadget
let's say transforms
a constant number of rows
and columns of the grid
into a cube that's
sticking out of your sheet.
And the key property is
it works even if there
are bumps on your
sheet elsewhere.
So when I say elsewhere, let me
show you the cube gadget again.
There's actually two columns
sort of getting used up here.
And there's one row
getting used up there.
Sorry, actually one row here.
So there's one row and two
columns in this corner.
And there's actually one
row and two columns used up
in each corner.
And that material disappears
in some sense from the folding
up here.
But all the other
stuff, this column,
everything out in this
corner, and those four squares
around the center
and the center square
itself, those can
all have bumps.
You better not have bumps
here where I need to fold.
But everywhere else
can have bumps.
And it's OK-- so I just need
to set up my bump pattern so
that when I finish
making that cube,
I have the bumps
in the right place.
So it's sort of a working
backwards process.
And the idea is to
make a tree of cubes.
So if you want to make
something that has cycles in it,
like a big n by n
by n cube array,
you can just cut it
up, subdivide it,
so that it's just
a tree of objects.
So for example, suppose I wanted
to build this shape, which
is not really a tree.
I can just pretend that
there's a slice here.
So these guys are
connected in a path.
But they're not connected here.
In general, you can
just keep slicing
until your thing is
connected like a tree.
Then once you have a tree,
you may know this fact,
every tree has at least two
leaves except in winter.
But in this context,
we're thinking of a tree.
Here the tree is just this path.
And a leaf is a vertex
that has degree one.
And every leaf has
at least, every tree
has at least two leaves
is a fun fact about trees.
And so what we do to make
this thing is make a leaf.
So what I mean is we
start with a blank sheet.
And we'll say OK, here's a leaf.
I'm going to build
that cube first.
So you apply cube gadget.
You build a cube.
Then you effectively
remove that leaf.
Just pretend it was never there.
This is sort of a
conceptual thing.
You're not really removing
it, but and then you repeat.
It's actually a super
simple algorithm.
The details are a
little bit tricky,
because we have to make
sure that this works.
But once I remove that cube,
now my graph is like this.
So I have a choice.
I could either fold this leaf
next, or I could fold this one.
I just keep going.
In this case, I could just
go linearly along the path,
like I did for making
the overhanging L.
And you will make all the cubes.
And the property you'll have is
that whenever I build a cube,
all the things that
were hanging off of it
have already been built.
Because I'm always working
from the leaves up the tree.
This is, for those
who know trees,
this is called a
post-order traversal.
It just means whenever
I touch a node, whenever
I create a node, all
of its descendants, all
of the leaves below it,
have already been built.
And that's exactly how
this thing needs to work.
Because you can have
existing bumps which
are the things that were
attached to that cube
and sort of are
deeper in the tree.
Those are harder.
You can't make those later.
As long as they're
already built,
you just sort of keep
working up the tree.
And the stuff you've
already built hangs off.
In the end, you'll
have your entire tree.
And you'll have your polycube.
That's it.
So there are obviously details
here that I'm skipping.
But I think this is
a fun essence of it.
Another fact, this is
essentially optimal.
So I'm using an n by n grid
to make around n cubes.
You might hope in some
cases you can do better.
In some cases, you can make
n squared cubes out of an n
by n grid.
That's the best case.
The worst case
really is n cubes.
Because if you want to
make a super long polycube,
a one by one by n grid, then
the diameter of this thing
is about n.
And the diameter of my
square paper is like
maybe root 2 times n.
So maybe I could
save a root 2 factor.
But just to get this diameter
n, I'm going to need about an n
by n sheet.
So in the worst case,
this is the best
you can hope for from
our usual diameter
argument like last class.
But sometimes you can do better.
So for example, here is an
MIT made by Aviv Ovadya.
And this is much more
efficient, in some sense
because everything
here is height one.
You can share a lot
of those pleats.
You don't have to waste rows
for every single gadget.
You just, you can
share those wasted rows
along all the guys
who are aligned.
And general picture,
this is actually
Aviv's master's thesis.
The way I described it, if you
wanted to make two cubes right
next to each other, you fold
two separate cube gadgets
that each use up their
rows and columns.
You can be a little bit more
clever like I was saying
and share those used up
rows between the two guys.
Because they are
horizontally aligned.
And it's a little
more efficient.
And that's essentially
what's done in that example.
But there's still some
sort of wastage here.
You don't really
need to do that.
You really want to build
the two by one thing.
And with some fancier version of
the algorithm, you can do that.
If you want to check
it out, you can
see Aviv's [INAUDIBLE]
thesis, which
was just completed last month.
And yeah, we don't have a formal
sense in which in how much
better this is.
But it's sort of
opportunistic, tries
to be as good as possible.
And that is one version
of box pleating.
But in the same spirit, I want
to talk about another situation
where we can do very well.
And here we can prove
that we can do very well.
So again, trying to
be more efficient
and this sort of square wasted.
We have n squared of material.
We only make n things.
Be really nice if we could make
n squared things out of an n
by n grid.
And oh, here's another
fun example which uses
all those optimizations
building a car.
This one there's a real version
of, but I don't have it here.
And where we can be particularly
efficient is maze folding.
So suppose you take a
graph on an n by n grid.
Here it happens
not to be square.
And then you just sort
of extrude that graph
out from the sheet.
That would give you
a bunch of walls
in an orthogonal, 3D pattern.
Let's say I extrude by one
unit, one unit of this square.
And I claim I can
fold this 3D shape
from a square of paper
that is just 3n by 3n.
So it's just a constant
factor shrinkage.
And this is essentially the
best you could hope for.
Yeah, should I try to argue it.
So if you look at where did
this material come from,
well you've got to go up
this wall, down this wall,
over the side, up the
wall, down the wall,
over, over, over,
over, up, down.
And in general, you
have to go up and down
and along the floor.
So that's three for every
square that you have here.
So that's maze folding.
And this is work with
Jason Ku and Marty, also
from the big origami
conference this summer.
So you could call it a maze.
You could call it a graph.
But it's orthogonal.
It's on the grid.
And it's extruded from an
n by n square let's say.
And that thing can be
folded from an order n
by order n square of paper.
And if you're extruding by one
unit, this big O at that three.
And to me this is
really exciting.
Because one of the big mysteries
to me in origami design
is in practical origami, you
usually start with a sheet.
And you make something that's
like two or three times smaller
and never much more.
And it would be really nice
to capture theoretically
what things can you make by only
shrinking by a constant factor.
Like checkerboards,
we know, or we think,
you have to shrink a lot.
For an n by n
checkerboard, you have
to shrink by like factor
of n over 2, n over 4,
whatever the best bound is.
But it seems the more
complicated you want,
the more you have to fold.
Here, I can make a
super complicated maze.
It could be a
million by million.
And I'm still only shrinking
the sheet by a factor of three.
So this is one of
the few results
we know where you can
get a large class,
and yet you're only
shrinking by small factor.
The proof of this is also
pretty easy, in fact even easier
than the previous one.
Again, we're going
to use gadgets.
And we're going to combine
them in different ways.
But the idea is we
just make a gadget
for each possible
vertex in this graph.
So a vertex in the graph could
have no edges incident to it.
So we call this degree 0.
Or it could have one incident
edge and the rest are absent.
That's degree 1.
Or it could have
two incident edges.
And there's two ways
it could be like that.
It could be a turn or
it could be straight.
You could have three
incident edges.
Or you could have
four incident edges.
So that's all the
possible vertices
in our orthogonal graph.
And we're just going to make
a crease pattern, a folding
for each one of these and then
just combine them together.
Now it takes a lot of care
in designing those patterns
that they actually fit together.
But all you need to know
is that it can be done.
And they're not trivial.
But once you have
them, it's easy.
So you've got
degree 0 on the top,
degree 2 straight, degree 4,
degree 3, degree 1, degree 2
turned.
And they're at, I guess, an
increasing order of difficulty.
And we need to know
that these things exist.
One way is to in some
sense just to draw
the picture of the folded state.
But there's so many layers
here it's a little hard to see,
and so in order to really
prove that these things exist,
Jason drew diagrams of how
these things could actually
be folded in isolation.
In some sense, we only care
about this final 3D picture
in knowing that it works and is
non self-intersecting and all
that.
But to show that
these exist, one way
is to actually
build them or show
the sequence that got there.
But in reality, you
wouldn't fold it this way.
Because what you do is you
take these crease patterns
on the left and just start
pasting them together.
It's like a big
cut and paste job.
So you say, oh well maybe like
if I made the square of turns,
I would just take one of
these, copy, rotate, put it
here, copy, rotate, put it
here, copy, rotate, put it here.
And that would make a
square root of turns.
And what you need
for that to work
is that the interfaces
here are compatible.
You can think of it
in the crease pattern,
or you can think of
it in the 3D state.
The interface in all
of these pictures
is that when you have an
actual edge that's raised,
it's very simple.
It just goes over,
up, down, over.
And when you have an edge that
doesn't exist, you go over
and then you have
a pleat underneath.
And then you go over.
And it's important that those
are the same total length.
Because you need to be
able to choose whether it's
a raised edge or
a non-raised edge.
And because all of those
interfaces are the same,
all of the down edges are
this kind of double pleat.
And all of the up edges
are just the ridge.
These things fit together.
And you can see that in
the crease pattern also.
Here's what the
pleat looks like.
And it can match with
this pleat or this one.
You can rotate.
Here is the ridge.
It just goes up and back down.
And you just paste
those together.
And you get your
desired crease pattern.
So here's a simple example.
The graph has almost all the
vertices, everything except 0
I think, and straights.
All right, not
quite all of them.
But I've color coded here.
So like you take the graph.
You just embed it on a
slightly larger grid.
And you replace each
of those vertices
with the crease pattern
that makes that thing.
You just have to rotate
it for it to work out.
And then you see that
all of these creases
just meet up correctly.
And then that's your crease
pattern, which will fold this.
So that once you
have the gadgets,
the algorithm is super
simple, just a bunch
of cutting and pasting.
And you can do more
complicated examples.
Here's an actual maze.
Get some pretty complicated
crease patterns.
Not so easy to fold.
But it can be done.
I didn't bring the
physical model of this,
because it actually looks
better in photograph.
It's a challenge.
This was folded by an
undergrad here, Chris Chin.
And in fact, it's such
an easy an algorithm,
I implemented it as
a web application.
It runs in JavaScript.
And you can go play with it.
It's [INAUDIBLE].
And you can say, OK
give me a random maze.
And you get a 3D representation.
And you get your crease pattern.
You hit print.
It will print out this
part in vector forms,
nice high resolution,
and all that.
You can make more mazes.
If you really want to
make a particular maze,
you can fool around with that.
And you can also write
important messages
like something like that.
And then you get this
3D representation,
which you can fold by this
simple crease pattern.
If you make that, one
please send it to me.
But that may take several hours
and use a big sheet of paper.
I mean, you're only shrinking
by a constant factor.
How hard could it be?
The answer is quite hard,
because the gadgets interact.
It's tricky.
All right, that's maze folding.
Any questions about maze
folding or this stuff?
I think that's the end of
positive results for today.
And we move into NP-hardness.
Good?
All right, well every
origamist knows,
and if you've been
working on a problem set,
you should know by
now origami is hard.
And we'd like to
prove that formally.
And because we're
computer scientists,
we like to know what we
can't know essentially.
There are a lot
of problems where
there's no efficient algorithm.
And instead of
just giving up, we
like to prove that no one can
find an efficient algorithm.
Because then we know
we're kind of done.
That's comforting.
And NP-hardness,
let me change this,
I don't want to
formally define it.
Because it's a
little bit technical.
But a working
definition, there are
lots of working definitions
that are super easy to tell you.
So the informal version
is that NP-hard problems
are computationally
intractable problems,
meaning there's no tractable
way, no efficient way, to solve
it on a computer.
But what it really means,
or what it really implies,
is if a problem is NP-hard, then
there's no efficient algorithm.
I wish we could just say that.
But there's a slight
catch, unless P=NP.
How many people know
about NP-hardness?
Well, how many people don't?
Just a few.
All right, I'm going to go
relatively quickly then.
Those who haven't heard
NP-hardness and haven't heard
of P=NP?
Good.
So you've all heard about
this famous problem.
It's almost certainly the
case that P does not equal NP.
Pretty much everyone
believes that,
unless you watch my April Foo;s
video and search for P equals
NP in YouTube.
And what this means intuitively
is that there's no cheating.
There's no trick to make
lucky guesses in life.
If you've got two choices
and you don't know which is
the right choice,
and you're computer,
you can't-- computers
aren't lucky.
The best they can do
is try both options.
That's what P does not
equal NP means basically.
There are no lucky, there's
no way to simulate luckiness.
That's the technical version.
Those who know NP
should agree with me.
That is real.
It's not how most
people explain it.
But it's how I like
to think about it.
And from that perspective,
it's kind of obvious.
But it's very annoying.
It's unlikely anyone will
prove this in the near future,
says Scott Aaronson,
who bet $200,000
that that was the case.
Right.
So you don't need to know
the definition of NP-hardness
except that it probably means
there's no efficient algorithm.
For what we need here is
this idea of reduction,
that we can take some
hard problem, known
NP-hard problems.
Why did I write ness there?
NP-hard problems
show that a problem
that we care about,
like origami design,
is even harder than
those problems.
Therefore, it's also NP-hard.
That's the usual
way for NP-hardness.
It's always showing that your
problem is harder than another.
Or showing that one
of these problems
is easier than your problem.
And therefore, yours is harder.
So I'm going to need
three problems today.
I'll start just by defining two
of them, which you've probably
seen before.
One is called partition.
And I give you n numbers.
I want to know, can I split
them into equal halves?
Be a little more precise.
Two halves of equal sum.
So suppose you're playing
video game Team Deathmatch.
You've got two teams.
You've got a ranking
for every player.
You'd like to divide
your players so
that the sum of the
rankings on the red side
is the same as the sum of the
rankings on the blue side,
so it's an even game,
more fun, whatever.
This problem, sadly, is NP-hard.
There's no way to do
that, even approximately.
The only catch is this
problem is hard only
when these integers
are super big,
like exponentially large in n.
This problem is
called weakly NP-hard.
So as long as your player
rankings are nice and small,
there actually is an
efficient way to solve that.
Problem but when the integers
are big, this is NP-hard.
An even nastier problem
is satisfiability, or SAT.
Here you're given
some Boolean formula.
So it has a bunch
variables, like x and y.
You can do and.
You can do not.
And you can do or, let's say.
That's all you need,
x and not y or z.
And you want to know, can
I make that formula true?
Is there some setting to
the variables x, y, and z,
or in general there's
n variables, so
that the formula is true?
So we'd say the
formula's satisfied.
And that's NP-hard.
And here there's not even
any numbers to make it hard.
So we call this problem
strongly NP-hard.
And this is really the
prototypical hard problem,
NP-hard problem, is the very
first one is proved NP-hard.
It's the only one
really that we usually
prove without a
reduction, you could say.
So what we're going to do it
for four different origami
problems is show those problems
are easier than our problems.
Therefore, our problems
are NP-hard also.
How do we show that,
say a partition
is easier than some problem?
Well, we just take a parti--
we show that partition
is a special case
of our problem.
It's a special case.
Clearly it's easier.
So to show that, we take one
of these partition problems,
like n integers.
We want to know whether you
can split them in equal halves.
I'm going to convert
that into my problem,
so that that problem has
a yes answer if and only
if the partition problem
has a yes answer.
Therefore, really this
problem becomes a special case
of the one I care about.
Therefore, that problem
is harder, and therefore
also NP-hard.
So I'm going to start out with
a super simple example which
we did in the problem
session on Monday.
Someone pose this to me after
class last week, I think.
I think two lectures ago.
So here's a problem.
I give you a single
vertex hinge pattern.
Someone built some crazy
robot with some crazy pattern
of hinges all around
a single vertex.
You want to know, can I
make anything out of it?
Does some subset
of those hinges,
if I take that as a
crease pattern, fold flat?
Who posed this problem?
Anybody remember?
All right.
Maybe he's not here.
I forgot, unfortunately.
He asked me, so what
about this problem?
I said, yeah it's
obviously NP-hard.
And we thought about
it for five minutes.
And then after five minutes,
it's obviously NP-hard.
So let me show you the
obvious proof once we have it.
We're going to show
that this problem is
harder than partition.
So we take n integers, want
to know how to divide them.
And it's really simple.
So suppose someone
gives us n integers.
For integers, we're
going to scale them
all by the same scale factor,
so that their sum equals
360 degrees.
And now, lo and
behold, those integers
are angles in a crease
pattern, in a hinge pattern.
So you just take those numbers.
You turn them.
You put them on a wheel.
OK.
Now presumably, it's not a flat,
foldable, single vertex crease
pattern.
Otherwise, the
answer would be yes.
We want to know, can I
remove some the creases
to make it flat foldable?
Now if you think about
Kawasaki's theorem,
the sum, the alternating
sum of angles equals 0.
Remember how that proof worked?
We said, OK you follow
one angle for a while.
Then you turn.
Then you go back.
And somehow, you have to end
up back where you started.
That's the equals zero part.
And it's the
alternating sum part.
Now in this case, we have
a choice at every crease.
We could include it or not.
If we include the
crease, we turn around.
If we remove the crease,
we keep going straight.
So now the problem is I
give you all these integers.
And I can go right.
And now I have a choice.
Do I go right or left by
the next integer, theta 2.
There's theta 1, theta 2.
Each one, I have a choice.
Do I go right or left?
In the end, the sum
must equal zero.
So this problem is
the same problem
really as given a
bunch of numbers,
can I assign signs of plus or
minus so that they add up to 0?
But assigning signs of plus
or minus so they add up to
is the same as saying all the
plus guys equal all the minus
guys.
So really, this problem becomes
assigning pluses and minuses,
so that the sum with
the appropriate pluses
or minuses of
theta i is equal 0.
That's the Kawasaki version.
But that's the same thing as
saying the sum of the pluses
equals the sum of the minuses.
And if that's the case,
then really you've
partitioned your numbers
into two halves of equal sum.
So this is going to be
possible exactly when there's
a partition.
And so you've
converted partition
into this problem, which
means this problem is harder.
Because it has other
situations maybe.
But you take any
partition, and are actually
pretty much identical.
But partition becomes a
special case with this problem.
Therefore, this problem is
harder, and therefore NP-hard.
It's only weakly NP-hard.
But that's a minor detail.
Clear?
All right.
Now we move on to the
more, I don't know,
that's a brand new result,
and a very simple one.
Now we move on to the sort of
more established, well-studied
problems.
The NP-hardness proofs are
quite a bit more complicated.
But they're still, they
all follow the same spirit.
And they're a lot of fun,
because they involve gadgets.
Here there aren't
really any gadgets.
We represented an
integer by an angle.
It's pretty direct.
But in some sense,
that's the gadget.
And we just used n of them.
All of the other proofs are
going to use tons of gadgets.
And they're kind of fun.
I love NP-hard proofs.
They're one of my
favorite things.
All right, one of
the first things
we talked about in this
class was simple folds.
And we showed that in
one dimension, if you
had a one dimensional
piece of paper,
simple folds were universal.
You could make any flat,
foldable crease pattern.
And if you remember,
at the very end,
we talked about
map folding, which
is where you have a bunch
of orthogonal creases
in a rectangular paper, and
maybe also with mountain valley
assignment.
And we showed that
this problem really
is a bunch of one
dimensional problems.
And so if we wanted to
solve it was simple folds,
where you only fold along
a single line at a time
by 180 degrees, then
really this turned
into a one dimensional
problem in one dimension, then
a one dimensional problem
in the other dimension.
You just kept doing
that until either you
got stuck, in which case the
thing was not flat foldable,
or you flat folded it.
So this is an example where
simple folding is easy.
But in general,
deciding whether you
can fold a crease pattern flat
by simple folds is NP-hard.
So for this special
case, it's easy.
For another situation, which
is when the polygons are not
just rectangles, but are
a little more general,
then it becomes NP-hard.
So in general, the problem
is given a crease pattern,
possibly with mountain
valley assignments,
doesn't really matter, can it
be folded flat by simple folds,
by a sequence of simple folds?
Initially we thought maybe
this problem was polynomially
solvable, because simple
folds are so damn simple.
We were wishful,
but it's not true.
This turns out to be NP-hard.
If we take this situation,
the map situation,
and we add 45 degree
folds, creases, so I just
add some things like that.
It looks kind of crazy.
Got to do some sub division.
I just add 45 degree folds.
Then this problem
becomes NP-hard.
So with orthogonal creases
in a rectangle, it's easy.
But you had one more
direction, it's hard.
Another version that's hard.
If I keep all the creases
horizontal and vertical
but I make an orthogonal polygon
instead of just a rectangle,
then it's also NP-hard.
I'm going to show this
one because it's easier.
But this actually just converts.
You can set up 45
degree folds so
that you are forced to make a
particular orthogonal polygon
to get started.
And then it's the same proof.
So I think I have
the proof here.
So again, we're going to
reduce from partition.
So we're given n integers.
We want to know whether
we can divide them
into equal summing halves.
And we're going to
represent those integers
by these lengths.
So here's an, then
a3, and a2, and a1.
So the lengths in the top part
of the staircase are integers.
We want to somehow divide
those into equal halves.
And when they have two halves,
and I suppose at their sum
is L, capital L. I can
just add them all up.
I should get 2L.
I divide by 2, I could get
what the target sum is.
So I know ahead of time without
solving the partition problem
what L ought to be, and
what twice L ought to be.
And then I build this frame
over on the right whose height
is exactly twice
L. And so there's
these creases in the horizontal
creases down the staircase.
All these creases have
to get folded eventually,
and by simple folds.
And then there's also
these two vertical creases
bounding the frame.
So the idea is, well you make
some of the horizontal creases.
Then you fold one of
those horizontal creases.
And then eventually you
have to fold-- I'm sorry,
one of those vertical creases.
I always get horizontal
and vertical confused,
which causes me great
difficulty when trying to sleep.
But so when I fold the first
vertical crease, whatever's
over here comes over here.
If it hits the frame,
I'm in big trouble.
Because then how
am I going to fold
the other horizontal,
other vertical crease
without colliding
with the frame?
If I want to avoid collision
with the frame by simple folds,
and I fold the vertical
crease, I really
should not be
touching the frame.
So you try to fold through it.
They're both valleys
in this case.
It doesn't matter too much.
So what I really need to do
is fold this thing compactly
like this, so that it just
fits inside the frame.
And the only way to
do that is for each
of those vertical
segments of the staircase
to decide should it go
up, or should it go down?
And you do that in
actually pretty much
the same way this proof works.
For each of these
segments here, we
were deciding should I
keep going straight and go,
or should I turn around?
Over here, it's the same deal.
I either keep going
straight, whichever direction
I was going, up or
down, or I turn around.
But I always have a
choice at every crease.
I'll just fold it or not to make
it go up or down how I want.
The up guys are going
to be one of the halves.
And the down guys are going
to be the other halves.
Here, it's the other
side of the paper,
the dark blue versus
the light blue.
As long as those numbers
add up to exactly L,
I've got this twice.
Then I start here at
the middle of the frame.
If I can get them
to balance out,
I will end over here,
also at the middle.
And then I go up by L.
And then I go down by 2L.
And that will just
fit inside the frame.
But only if I stay in
the middle will that 2L
fit inside the frame.
And so the only way
for these two creases
to be foldable and not
collide with the frame
is if I can solve the
partition problem.
Therefore, so finding
simple fold sequences
is actually way harder than
partition in some sense.
Because this is just
a very specific kind
of map, specific kind of crease
pattern you might want to fold.
And folding that is
exactly partition.
So the general simple
foldability problem
is going to be NP-hard,
because it includes partition
as a special case.
Clear?
Good.
That's our easiest proof
among the next three.
Going to get increasingly
difficult, I guess.
But I'll just getting
increasingly sketchy,
so it will be easy for me.
I mean, the more
complicated a proof gets,
somehow I feel like the
number of interesting details
in a proof remains constant.
If the proof gets
more complicated,
then I throw away more
of the messy details.
All right, the next theorem is
also about flat foldability.
But now I don't just
care about simple folds,
I want to look at
regular origami
folds, which are folded states.
So we talked a couple lectures
ago about local foldability,
which was can we
assign mountains
and valleys to
some crease pattern
so that each vertex, if you
cut it out into a little disk,
would by itself fold flat.
And that was easy, polynomially
solvable, actually linear time.
And that was a result
by Bern and Hayes.
Another result in the same
paper by Bern and Hayes,
which is actually sort
of the bigger result
that everyone knows about,
is that if I give you
an arbitrary crease
pattern, I want
to know just does it fold
flat, that's NP-hard.
They proved actually two
NP-hard hardness results.
So this is way back in '96.
This is one of
the oldest results
in computational origami.
So I give you a crease pattern.
I just want to know, is it
flat foldable in the global,
in the regular sense?
This is strongly NP-hard.
The proof I just gave is
actually weakly NP-hard.
It is not known whether that
problem is strongly or weakly
hard, but at least weekly.
The other thing they
proved is that if you're
given a flat foldable, even I
tell you it's flat foldable,
and I even give you the
mountains and valleys that
make it work, still flat
folding thing is NP-hard.
So if I give you a flat foldable
mountain valley pattern,
all that's left is to decide
I can fold each vertex.
And then there's this
issue of layering.
If I have two layers of
paper that are overlapping,
they could be like this.
Or they could be like this.
And if I have, for
example, two crimps,
I could decide
how the layers go.
Figuring out what the
right layer ordering is
is really the heart
of the problem.
This is what makes it NP-hard.
Because we know finding a
mountain valley assignment--
locally things work-- is easy.
But getting that
layering to work is hard.
That's what all
these proofs say.
So I'm going to talk about
the proof of the first result
though, because the second
one is pretty complicated.
It's the same spirit,
just a lot more details.
Again, we're going
to do a reduction.
And we have these two nice
problems, partition and SAT.
I'm not going to
use either of them,
though in theory
you could use SAT.
I'm going to reduce from one
of my favorite problems, one
of my favorite NP-hard
problems, I should say.
Wait, no.
That's the next proof.
This is not my favorite.
It's a pretty good one, though.
I do like it.
Is just a little more technical.
All positive, not
all equal 3SAT,
has anyone heard of
this problem before?
Nadia's heard of it, because
she TA'd this class before.
It's no surprise.
So you've read the book.
This is, there aren't a lot
of proofs that use this one.
But not all equal 3SAT is
actually fairly common.
All positive is just makes
a little more convenient.
I think actually the original
proof didn't use all positive.
But our book does.
Because it simplifies things.
So let me tell you
what this problem is.
Most people don't know it.
So don't worry.
You could technically,
it's a version of SAT.
But instead of giving
a Boolean formula,
I'm going to think of that
it's really a Boolean formula.
But I'm going to think of
it in a simpler way, which
is I give you a bunch of triples
if variables, so like xi,
xj xk.
And I want to know is
there a Boolean assignment
to those variables?
I want to set each of
them to true or false.
Say there's n variables.
So that no triple is
all equal, no triple
is all true or all false.
Maybe we could call it
the all state problem.
I've been watching too many ads.
All right, so if not all equal
3SAT, that's this version.
Actually, it's
also all positive,
meaning I don't have
any nots in here.
So ignore that.
Ignore the technical term.
This is the right definition.
So I have a bunch of
triples of variables.
I just don't want them all to
be true or all to be false.
So two of them could be true
and one false, or two of them
could be false, and one true.
That's all.
It turns out this is
basically equivalent to SAT.
But the proof of that
is kind of messy.
So I don't want to do it here.
And so that problem is NP-hard.
Just take that on faith.
And now I want to show that
global flat foldability
includes all positive
not all will equal 3SAT
as a special case.
And therefore,
it's also NP-hard.
So I'll give you a preview.
Start with a high level, what
we need in terms of gadgets.
And then I'll show
you the gadgets,
and then show you how
they fit together.
So this is a general
picture, in fact,
of what a SAT kind of
NP-hardness proof looks like.
If you haven't done many
of them, now you'll know.
If you have done
many of them, you
will recognize
this pattern, which
is to represent
Boolean-ness, we need
something that represents
true and false.
And that's usually
called a wire.
We think of digital
signals like chips.
And then we've got to be able
to connect those wires together
to do interesting things.
In this case, the interesting
thing we need to do
is tell if I have
a triple of them,
are they all true or
all false, and somehow
force them to not be
all true or all false.
And in this case, that will
be a not all equal clause.
It'll be a gadget
the folds flat,
exactly when those wires that
come together, three wires
come together.
And if they're all truth,
they won't fold flat.
If they're all false,
it won't fold flat.
In all of the cases,
it will fold flat.
So if we could
build that, that'll
constrain the variables
that I connect together
with a not all equal clause.
But how do I actually
move the wires around
to make them connect
together at these clauses?
Well, I need something
called a turn gadget.
If I have a wire
going straight, I'd
like to be able to turn
it to some other angle.
I could just sort
of move them around.
It's harder than it sounds.
And I'll also need a split.
Because in this, it's maybe not
obvious from this formulation,
but I have these n variables.
I might have many
more than n clauses.
Each variable, like
x1, might appear
in 100 different triples.
And so I actually
need 100 copies of x1.
And that's what a
split gadget does.
And we're going to
build one gadget called
a reflector, which actually
does both of those in one
fell swoop.
And the last thing we
need is a crossover.
Because you make all these
connections between variables
and clauses or triples.
And they might have
to cross each other.
And we want them to
cross each other,
but not affect each other.
And because we're
in a sheet of paper,
we've got to deal with that.
It's going to be these wires
to go right through each other.
We got to make it
still flat foldable
without affecting either wire.
That's all.
That's pretty standard
for this kind of proof.
These are the proofs that
I like the most, actually.
Pretty fun.
So in our case, a wire is
going to be super easy.
It's just pleat, so two very
nearby parallel creases.
And because they're nearby,
I mean, if you look locally,
it's like a one
dimensional problem.
They can't both be valley
or both be mountain.
Because then these
two big panels
would intersect each other.
So one of them is valley,
one of them is mountain.
There's exactly two choices.
I'm going to always
have an arrow on my wire
so I have a sense
of orientation,
which way the signal is going.
And once I have an
orientation, the left side,
if the left side is
valley, that's true.
If the left side is
mountain, that's false.
That's just I'm going
to decide it that way.
It doesn't actually matter,
because in this problem,
true and false are symmetric.
But I just need to be
consistent about which is which.
OK, so that was the wire gadget.
The next one is the
not all equal gadget.
And I'm guessing this is
where Bern and Hayes started.
Because it's sort of
the heart of the proof.
Then there's all these details
to connect up with the wires,
and split them, and whatnot.
But this is something
called a triangular twist.
You may have folded one before.
It's kind of classic.
So the crease pattern's
in the top left.
And the idea is I have
three wires coming together.
I want this thing to fold flat
if, and only if, the wires are
not all the same.
And I've drawn here sort of
three of the possible patterns
you could have.
Here I have one
truth and two false.
That folds flat.
Here I have three false.
And here I have two
true and one false.
This also folds flat.
In all cases, this is what
the folded state looks like.
I maybe never mentioned this.
But this is an
important concept.
If you take a crease pattern and
you say I want to fold it flat,
you can tell where
all the stuff is
going to go in
terms of geometry.
What you can't tell
is the layer ordering.
That depends on the
mountain valley assignment.
That depends on how you
decide the layers to stack.
But you can tell already where
everything goes in the plane.
Because you pick, let's see,
did anything stay fixed here.
Yeah, the triangle stayed fix.
So you pick some face to
stay fixed, like that center
triangle.
You put it there.
And then you say, OK.
Well, where is this flap?
Where is this face of the
crease pattern going to go?
Well, it gets reflected
through that horizontal line.
So it goes here.
And you can just keep
playing this reflection game.
Because you know every
crease geometrically,
it's a reflection.
It could be a reflection
this way or this way.
But it just, as soon
as you cross a crease,
you end up reflecting
your material.
And so you can draw this
picture without knowing anything
about how it's folded.
Just if there's a flat folding,
it's got to look like this.
And the annoying
thing about this
set up, because that angle
up there is 35 degrees,
these guys are going to
overlap in this common center.
And in this situation where
it's all false or all true,
you get an intersection there.
It's a little tricky to prove.
And you've just got
to fiddle with one.
I should have brought
one, but that is true.
And so in the all false and
symmetrically the all true
case, this thing
does not fold flat.
In all the other
situations, it folds fine.
Because the layers
get out of the way.
OK, also over here, and there's
a bunch of these in the book,
are little analyses of
which of the creases
have to have the same
mountain valley assignment
and which have to
have different.
That's actually how
these patterns are drawn.
This is from our old local
analysis of a single vertex
crease pattern, right.
You've got these four creases.
Check it out.
The only one that could
be crimped is this one.
Because it's globally smallest.
All the other guys have a bigger
neighbor or are in trouble.
So this guy has to be crimped.
So these two are not equal.
And therefore, these
two must be equal.
And that's symmetrical
all the way around.
So in fact, you know
that this crease
is different from this
one, is equal to this one.
You already knew that
these two are different.
So that's OK.
So you can figure out
these crease patterns.
There's a little bit of flexi--
once you have the mountains
and valleys coming in, you know
how the mountains and valleys
have to be in the center.
Just makes life easier.
There's only one mountain
valley assignment
you need to consider.
And the symmetric one
turns out to be bad.
So that's two gadgets.
We got the wire, the
not all equal clause.
Of course, if we're
lucky, all the wires
will just meet at
the right points.
But I'm going to need
many copies of them.
I've got to move
them around to reach
all the different clauses,
all the different triples.
So next up is reflector.
This is actually in
some sense really easy.
So we have, here's our input.
What the reflector is
going to do is it's
going to make two copies, one
down here which is negated,
and one up here, which
is the same value.
And it also effectively
turns the signal
two different directions.
So to see why it works
is actually pretty easy.
It's just a local
analysis again.
You look at this vertex.
This is the only increase
they could be crimped.
So we know that these two
guys have opposite assignment.
Therefore, these two wires
will have opposite value.
And actually, they
have the same value
if they're pointing
in the same direction.
But they'll have
opposite value because I
decided this one's
pointing down.
So if this one's a mountain,
this one has to be a valley.
And so if this is true because
it's valley on the left,
this one's false because
it's mountain on the left.
OK, and then you can
do the same thing.
Then you also know these
two guys are equal.
And because again, this is
the only crimpable pair here,
these two creases are not equal.
And so you know these
two guys are equal
and these two guys are equal.
And so you know that this
valley is propagated up there.
And therefore, these two
wires have the same value.
So you've split the signal.
You've made a positive
copy and a negated copy.
And if you just do
this again, you'll
get-- this will make
another negated copy
and a positive copy.
So I get two positive
copies and a negated one.
You can just keep
doing this and you'll
get tons of positive copies,
tons of negative copies.
So it doesn't even matter
if it's all positive.
But if you take
all positive ones.
Let the others go
off to infinity.
And now you want to
move around so that they
hit those not all equal clauses.
How do I move them around?
I just use more reflectors.
If I come in at some
angle, I can now
turn by however much that is.
Or I can turn by
however much that is.
I'm not going to try to figure
out what those angles are.
But it turns out, this is
enough to make everything work.
The last thing you need are
a bunch of crossover gadgets.
This is one of them.
There's a second one.
I'll just wave my
hands and say, if you
take two pleats in
the obvious way,
they really don't
care about each other.
Because the way to
fold this locally,
is to fold this diagonal
pleat and then fold
the vertical pleat.
And it will work whether
one pleat is true or false.
It doesn't matter which side is
valley, which side is mountain.
It always works.
So crossovers aren't
actually that big a deal.
Once you have that,
you take those gadgets.
And you put them together
into a monstrosity
of a crease pattern, which
looks something like this.
And this took forever
to draw, I remember.
So we have on the left
side our variables.
These are just wires.
They're pleats.
And each one could be
folded true or false,
left over right or
right over left.
And then I do a whole
bunch of reflectors,
just reflect, reflect,
reflect, reflect, reflect,
just to make a whole
bunch of copies.
And then at the top there, way
at that little yellow triangle,
is a not all equal clause.
And is a not all equal
clause between x3,
where we make a copy.
Wow, this is crazy.
I end up making a copy,
negate it downwards,
and I flip it around.
And it goes up straight.
And then I turn it at an angle
to hit the triangle dead on,
the way it's supposed to.
Then I also take x1
up the top, just get
a copy straight
off the top there.
And x2, I take a copy here.
For some reason I feel like
negating it, and turning it
around, and spitting
it up there.
And then I turn it back down.
It hits the yellow triangle
at just the right angle.
And therefore, if this
thing's going to fold flat,
it must be that x1, x2,
and x3 are not all equal.
And you just keep doing
that, one for every triple.
Remember, we're given as input
one of these not all equal SAT
problems.
I give you a bunch of triples.
I just put the wires together
according to those triples.
This thing we flat
foldable if and only
if this formula is satisfiable.
You can set the pleats so that
the desired triples are not
equal.
So that's pretty crazy.
This is in some sense
one of the hardest proofs
that we will see.
But in the end,
you get NP-hardness
of flat foldability.
Questions?
OK, I want to do one
more proof sketch.
This is yet another
paper that was
at this year's Origami in
Science Math and Education
conference.
This is, it's fun
to teach this class.
Because it changes so much
over a period of three years.
Lots of new results.
This is a result
with a guy named
Sandor Fekete from Germany.
He does a lot of optimization,
and Robert Lang, and myself.
So disk packing is something
we talked about last class
in the context of the tree
method of origami design.
We said, in particular we were
thinking of this situation
where we wanted to make them
a Margulis napkin counter
example.
So this was equivalent.
If we wanted to build this
uniaxial base and sides,
was the same thing as packing
n disks into a square.
That's what the
tree method shows.
So in some sense, I'm
talking about this problem.
But equivalently, I'm
talking about this problem
of packing disks into a square.
Now if I give you n unit
disks all the same size,
I want to pack them in a square,
that problem cannot be NP-hard.
That's annoying.
But the input is only n.
It's not very interesting.
So to make it harder, be able
to show that this problem is
computationally
intractable, I'm going
to consider
generalization, which
is I still have this
kind of star tree,
still a very simple
kind of uniaxial base I
might want to build.
But now all the limbs
are different lengths.
So what that corresponds to is
I have disks of various sizes.
It's kind of fun.
It's like bubbles.
They all have to fit.
They can't overlap each other.
All of the centers of the
disks are inside the square.
And I want to know,
can I-- how big
a square do I need to pack them?
OK, I'm going to formulate it as
a decision question, yes or no.
Can you place n given disks,
I give you the sizes of them.
I want them to be
non-overlapping.
They can touch on the
boundary but the interiors
can't overlap.
And I need the centers
to lie in a given square.
So I want to know, can I
make this uniaxial base
from this square paper?
And I claim that as NP-hard.
So good luck solving
it perfectly.
And what tree maker
does is it solves
it approximately
with a heuristic.
For those who know
approximation algorithims,
this is a problem you can find
a constant factor approximation.
There's one in the same paper.
But it's still not,
still unresolved
how close to
optimal you can get.
But I want to focus
here on the NP-hardness.
So I should say this
problem is NP-hard.
So we're going to prove that.
And now I get to reduce
for my favorite problem,
favorite NP-hard.
It's my favorite partly
because not many people know it
unless you've done NP-hardness
proofs with me before.
And it's very powerful.
Whenever you have a problem
that involves numbers,
and this problem
involves numbers.
It's the radii of the disk's.
Three partition is the
problem you should know.
Partition is all right.
The three partition
is like 50% better.
Because partition is like you've
partitioned it to two parts.
So it's like two partition.
Three partition,
you partition into?
Does not one have
the right answer?
I hear three parts
and five parts.
Any other guesses?
AUDIENCE: Seven
PROFESSOR: Seven.
Keep going.
n over three parts
is the answer.
So it's not so obvious.
Maybe it should be called
n over 3 partition.
So instead of the number
of parts being three,
the size of each part is three.
So n should be divisible by 3.
So I'm going to
partition it to n over
3 triples of numbers
of equal sum.
This problem is cool for
this technical reason
that it is strongly NP-hard.
So even when the numbers are
really small, like about n,
this problem is NP-hard.
With partition, the numbers
had to be exponential and n
for the problem to be hard.
And that's kind of
artificial here.
So this is actually
strongly NP-hard.
So this problem
is hard even when
the disk sizes are
not that different.
There's like a range between
one and n, let's say.
If I reduce from partition,
I'd need some disks
to be microscopic and
some to be ginormous,
exponential difference.
I'm going to reduce
from three partition
because I get a better result.
I get a stronger result the
says even when the disks are not
so different in size,
this problem is NP-hard.
That's my problem that
I've got to start from.
So I give you n integers.
I want to somehow triple
them up using a disk packing.
So somehow solving a
disk packing problem
is going to solve this
three partition problem.
And it's kind of crazy.
I'll give you the
high level picture.
It's n over three
identical pockets.
So in this case, there
is kind of like the proof
where we had the simple folds
and we a frame and some stuff.
We're going to have some
infrastructure, which
in that case was the frame.
That was sort of a basic
thing that always exists.
In this case, we're going to
have some infrastructure which
is a whole bunch of disks
that just sort of set,
instead of having this very
open problem, open playing
field with a square, and like
you could put disks anywhere,
I want to partition
my square into lots
of little pockets, all the
same size, all the same shape.
And all other pockets are
going to be much smaller.
So it's a little
hard to draw this.
Because while I said
that the disks aren't
that different size,
they're only a factor of n
different in size, if you
try to draw these pictures,
it gets tiny very quickly.
So here's the high
level picture.
You have a square.
And I'm going to put
down these disks.
There's 20 disks here, I
think, 4 times 4 is 16 plus 5.
I'm sorry, 21.
So these 21 disks, they
have a unique package,
this one right here.
You can see that
because these four disks
have to be in the corners,
can't fit one in the center
and have room for the others.
Then this guy has
to go right there.
And then these four disks are
unique if you set it up right.
It's a little bit,
it's hard to draw.
But these are little bit
wedged over to the right.
So you set up these disks.
That's infrastructure.
It's the only way to put them.
And then there's these
little pockets here.
They're nice.
They're symmetric.
They're like a triangle,
an equilateral triangle
so to speak, except
they have curved edges.
They're all the same size.
That gives me four pockets.
But I want n over 3 pockets.
So I'm going to need a lot more.
So I take each of these pockets.
That's these three disks.
And this is the triangular
pocket in the center.
And I put down these 17 disks.
It's almost the same.
And I can see it's not
quite drawn perfectly.
This is supposed to touch here.
This guy is floating
a little bit.
And what we end up, this
guy's uniquely placed.
And then these guys have got
to go in the three remaining
pockets.
What we end up getting is
another equilateral whole
pocket right there.
And these three will have the
same size and be identical.
If I do that in
all four of these,
now I'll have 16 pockets.
And each time I do
this, side I quadruple
the number of pockets.
So after I do it,
whatever log n times,
or I apply that
gadget around n times,
I get around n over 3 pockets.
They're all identical.
The ones I don't want, I'll
just throw a disk in there
to destroy it.
That's the infrastructure.
Now I've got n over
three identical pockets.
There are these other pockets.
Just throw in disks in there.
I mean, I can't force
them to go there.
But if you set disks
to the right size,
they really have to go there.
And so all of the other
pockets will get even tinier.
It will destroy them.
That's the infrastructure.
It's already pretty crazy.
But then the last
part is actually kind,
is very cool and elegant.
So I've got these
n over 3 pockets.
And this was the central
idea we started with.
It actually took us
awhile to find this way
to force a bunch of
identical pockets.
It's easy if you start
from a triangle of paper
or a rectangle of paper.
But we really wanted
to start from a square.
So that's the case we
care about in origami.
And so we came up
with that proof.
This is hard to draw perfectly.
Here's an equilateral
triangle, so to speak,
of equal radius disks
pairwise kissing.
A little slightly
wrong aspect ratio.
But you get the idea.
I'm going to put a disk here
that has a little bit of slack.
I'm going to put a disk
here that-- actually, I'm
going to draw them
without slack first.
And then I'm going to
say how the slack is.
Because that'll be
clearer what I mean.
So suppose this guy was
actually kissing all three.
And this guy was
kissing three and it's
like a bunch of threesomes here.
All right, now I want to
make each of these disks
a little bit bigger, which
will make this impossible.
But then I'm going to make
this guy a little bit smaller.
So I'm going to make
this one ai bigger.
I'm going to make
this one aj bigger.
this one ak bigger.
And this one, what did
I call it, L, smaller.
So L is the target
sum for a triple,
meaning I take all the
integers that I'm given.
And I add them all up.
And then I divide by n over 3.
That's what every
triple should sum to.
Because they're all
supposed to be the same.
So I call that L. This is
the sum divided by n over 3.
So I'm going to make this
one that much smaller.
This is all slightly
approximate.
Bear with me.
So that gives it a
little bit of slack,
which is good because these
guys are little bit bigger.
And if they are bigger, in total
if the sum of these two values
is L, this will barely fit.
If it's bigger than
L, it won't fit.
If it's less than
L, it will fit.
But because L has
to be, L is always
the average sum of the
triples, if they're all
going to-- if you have
a bunch of triples,
all of whose sum is less
than or equal to L, in fact
they all have to be exactly
equal L. Because there's
no slack.
So the only way for these guys
to pack, now I said this is ai,
aj, ak, in fact I'm just giving
you a heap, a bag of disks.
I don't say which ones go where.
You have to choose.
So clearly, these are
all the same size.
And they're just going
to go in the center.
And they'll wiggle
around a little.
These guys, you get to
choose how I triple them up
and how I put them into
these n over 3 pockets.
So that's your flexibility
in disk packing.
It's your only flexibility
in disk packing,
is how you triple them up.
And the only way
for it to work is
if you can triple them up
so that their sums, the sum
of the amount by
which they are bigger,
is exactly L. Because that's
exactly the slack of this disk.
And it will just fit.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So the fact that you
have an increase in the ai, j,
k [INAUDIBLE] geometry work out
with some tangents and stuff?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, all right.
So you raise a good point, which
is I said this is ai bigger.
I didn't really mean that
the radius is ai bigger,
although it's actually
close to that.
ai is an integer.
If I made it that much
bigger, it might be huge.
But what I really
mean is I take ai,
I multiply it by a very small
number greater than zero
called epsilon.
And all of these are
actually by epsilon.
And that is actually how
much you change the radius.
Maybe there's a
second order term.
But to the first order, yeah you
think, oh, there's this trig.
And I've got to do tangents
and all this funny stuff.
It turns out to the
first order, actually
things work really simply.
If I shrink this disk
by an additive amount,
or sorry, if I grow these
disks by and additive amount,
I shrink this by
the same amount,
this will still work up
to the first order, so up
to the first derivative.
So you might have to do
a little bit of fudging.
I can just subtract off an
epsilon squared or something
to give me just a
little bit of freedom.
And then this is actually
how big the disks are.
But you raise a good point.
There's details I'm hiding here.
It's actually pretty clean.
You work out the
tangents and things just
are pretty, surprisingly.
We thought this would be messy.
But it actually
works pretty well.
Other the questions?
All right.
Now you're experts at
NP-hardness of origami.
So here's the no equal
set clause gadget.
And if we fold it here
with all of the incoming
signals the same direction,
in the center they collide.
You can't go all
the way to flat.
This thing is not yet folded.
And it's stuck in the center.
But if I flip one of
them, I'll flip this guy,
then it very happily folds flat.
Because you don't get that
collision because the center
ends up going off to the side.
And you can check that for all
three, it's actually symmetric.
But no matter how these guys
are set, if they're all equal,
you get collision in the center.
If they're not all
equal, it folds flat.